نعم نعم. هذا هو قرارنا الاخير.
اذا اجرت واشنطن اي تجارب نووية
فسنضطر الى الرد باللغة التي
يعرفونها جيدا. بهذه الطريقة
خاطبت موسكو مجلس الامن الدولي.
اوكرانيا تنفذ عملية هي الاولى
من نوعها في الاراضي الروسية
وبوتين يشتاط غضبا فكيف سيرد.
ومجموعة العشرين تجتمع في الهند
لكن الصين وروسيا لهم مرصاد
ولقاء امريكي روسي والنتائج غير
مبشرة. بخمود تلفظ انفاسها
الاخيرة والجميع ينتظر اعلان
بوتين التاريخي. ووزارة الدفاع
الروسية تعلن مقتل ستمائة جندي
اوكراني في اربع وعشرين ساعة.
المانيا تعلن خسارة اي حرب قادمة
قبل بدايتها. فلتنفض غبار قبرك
يا هتلر. ومن قلب تايوان
الدليفري يغضب اصحاب العيون
الضيقة. واستراليا تكشف عورة
الامريكان وتعترف للصين والشرطة
تنقذ زوجة نتنياهو من بين مخالب
المتظاهرين. والسيسي يعلن عن
حزمة قرارات تاريخية. رياح
الحروب تنتقل الى روسيا.
وسيراتها خرقت اجواء موسكو لتوقظ
الدب الروسي من منامه. لكن كييف
لم تكتف لتبدأ اختراقها البري.
وذلك بعدما اعلنت روسيا عن قيام
مجموعة نكرانية تخريبية حد وصفها
بالتسلل الى منطقة كليموفسك في
مقاطعة بريانسك. هناك وقع عدد من
القتلى والجرحى بالاضافة الى
احتجاز رهائن وفق وكالة نوفوستي.
ليعلن الكريملين الغاء الرئيس
الروسي فلاديمير بوتين زيارته
المجدولة الى هناك بسبب الوضع في
بريانسك. ليقول نائب ان بوتين
ترأس اجتماعا طارئا لمجلس الامن
الروسي بعد الاحداث في بريانسك
بحسب روتينز. فاي رد مناسب يتخذه
بوتين. زعيم الكرملين لم يفصح عن
ردة فعله بعد. ولكنه قال ان
النازيين الجدد ارتكبوا عملا
ارهابي اخر في مقاطعة بريانسك
واطلقوا النار على المدنيين ومن
الاراضي الروسية الى العاصمة
الهندية نيودلي. حيث تم مجموعة
الدول العشرين لتبرز ملفات
القضية الاوكرانية والتوتر
الامريكي الصيني على رأس قائمة
هذا الاجتماع ليقول وزير
الخارجية الامريكي انتوني بلينكن
ان واشنطن واثقة من ان هذا
الاجتماع سيدين الغزو الروسي
لاوكرانيا. لكن هذا الاجتماع فشل
في التوصل لاتفاق بشأن الحرب في
اوكرانيا بسبب معارضة الصين
وروسيا. قمة الدول العشرين كانت
للقاء قصير بين وزيري الخارجية
الروسي والامريكي. هنا قال
بلينكن انه طلب من نظيره الروسي
لافروف انها هذه الحرب العدوانية
والانخراط في عملية دبلوماسية
هادفة يمكن ان تؤدي الى سلام
عادل ودائم. مضيفا انه ابلغ
لافروف بان واشنطن مستعدة
للتعاون مع موسكو في مجال الحد
من الاسلحة النووية. ليرد لافروف
حرب اوكرانيا جاءت ردا على الحرب
التي كان يحضرها الغرب لنا منذ
سنوات. مضيفا ان زيارة بلينكن
لدول اسيا الوسطى الهدف منها
ادمو علاقات روسيا بتلك الدول
وفق تعبيره. ليأتي الرد الاقوى.
لكن من نائب وزير الخارجية
الروسي سيرجي رياكوف الذي قال ان
بلاده تعتبر طلب الولايات
المتحدة اتاحة الوصول للتفتيش
على المنشآت النووية قمة السخرية
في الظروف الحالية. رياكوف عاد
ليفضي فانه حال قررت واشنطن ان
تكون اول من يجري تجارب نووية
فسنضطر الى الرد بشكل مناسب حسب
قوله. ليعود لافروف ويقول ان
الغرب يدفن مبادرة حبوب البحر
الاسود التي تسهل تصدير المنتجات
الزراعية الاوكرانية من موانئها
الجنوبية لتعود الحرب الباردة
للاشتعال مرة اخرى. وهنا يتدخل
الرئيس الصيني مشددا على تمسك
بلاده بالحل السياسي للازمة
الاوكرانية ونبذ عقلية الحرب
الباردة وبناء منظومة امنية
اوروبية متوازنة. ومن حرب الكلام
الى اصوات ضجيج القذائف
والصواريخ. حيث اعلن الجيش
الروسي انه تصدى لهجوم اوكراني
كثيف بطائرات مسيرة على منشآت في
شبه جزيرة الكرمة ذلك باسقاط
اربع مسيرات وتعطيل اربع اخريات
بواسطة الجيش الالكتروني الروسي.
بينما اعلنت الدفاع الروسية
اسقاط اربع عشرة مسيرة ومقاتلتين
ومروحية اوكرانية وتصفية اكثر من
ستمائة واربعين جنديا اوكرانيا
على مختلف المحاور. ليخرج سيرجي
رخمانين عضو لجنة الامن القومي
والدفاع والاستخبارات في
البرلمان الاوكراني ان الوضع في
باخموت حرج بالفعل فعاجلا ام
اجلا ستغادر القوات الاوكرانية
المدينة وفق وكالة نافوستي. ومن
الخسارة الاوكرانية الى العجز
الالماني. حيث قال وزير الدفاع
الالماني بوريس بيستوريوس ان
الجيش الوطني غير قادر على
الدفاع عن البلاد اذا تم فرض
حالة الحرب موضحا ان السبب في
ذلك هو ضعف القاعدة المادية كبير
في عدد الافراد لدى القوات
المسلحة الالمانية. بكين تضع
يدها في عنق واشنطن. يتبادلون
التجارة ويتراشقون بالهجمات. فهم
التجار وهم المتحاربون فعن اي
علاقة نتحدث بلغة الارقام تبدو
العلاقة بين اكبر اقتصادين في
العالم في احسن حال. كيف لا؟ وقد
فاق التبادل التجاري بين
الولايات المتحدة والصين ستمائة
وخمسين مليار دولار في العام
الفين وواحد وعشرين اي بزيادة
مائة مليار دولار عن العام الذي
سبقه. ومن لغة الارقام الى ارض
الواقع. هنا معهد السياسة
الاستراتيجية الاسترالي يكشف عن
سبب خسارة الولايات المتحدة
والدول الغربية سباقها مع الصين
في تطوير التكنولوجيا المتقدمة.
ليقول المعهد في تقريره ان الصين
تتقدم في السباق التكنولوجي في
سبع وثلاثين تقنية من اجمالي
اربع واربعين تقنية تعقبها
التقرير بالفحص وشملت البطارية
الكهربائية والتقنيات فوق
الصوتية واتصالات التردد
الراديوي المتقدمة فايف جي وسكس
جي فيا له من تقدم بارز لاصحاب
العيون الضيقة. ليعلن الامريكان
عن قرار اشعل الغضب لدى
الصينيين. حيث اعلن تايوان ان
المتحدة وافقت على صفقة اسلحة
معها بنحو ستمائة مليون دولار
بهدف تعزيز قدراتها الدفاعية
وتتضمن الصفقة صواريخ مضادة
للاشعاع وطائرات اف ستة عشر
وراجمات صواريخ. الدليفري
الامريكي لا يتوقف فكيف سيرد
اصحاب العيون الضيقة. الاحداث
والتطورات. السيسي يعلن زيادة
اجور في الدولة ليزداد بموجب هذه
الحزمة دخل الموظف بحد ادنى الف
جنيه شهريا. بينما تشتعل
المظاهرات في اسرائيل. زوجة
نتنياهو تصفف شعرها هناك حاصرها
المتظاهرون امام صالون حلاقة في
تل ابيب لتنفذ الشرطة
الاسرائيلية حملة لحمايتها. وزير
مالية الكيان الاسرائيلي يدعو
لمحو قرية فلسطينية وواشنطن تقول
هذه الدعوة مثيرة للاشمئزاز. قال
المدير العام للوكالة الدولية
للطاقة الذرية ان نتائج تحليل
عينات في منشأة فوردو الايرانية
اظهرت وجود جزيئات يورانيوم عالي
التخصيب بنسبة ثلاثة وثمانين
فاصل سبعة في المائة. الحرب
الاوكرانية تتجه نحو منعطف حرج
بوصولها للاراضي الروسية فكيف
سيكون الرد الروسي برأيكم. لكل
شخص شاركنا رأيه بالتعليقات
ودعمنا باللايكات.